then I will write say I promise but did
not do it so to prove theorem one
demonstrating some middle school
techniques I'll do it now because I
really like the proof so theorem one
said that if a I J is M by M complex
matrix such that all entries are within
distance one-half for one then the
permanent is not zero right so and
here's a proof we prove it by induction
on n but we prove a stronger statement
so induction on n
what do we prove we prove that if a a I
J and B Vij are two n by n matrix like
that one as a bomb that's where the
interest was in point five from one and
they differ just in one row or one
column at most
then not only the permanence in on zero
but if you think of the permanence the
complex number says vectors in the plane
then the angle between them doesn't
exceed PI over two
right so for n equal one that should be
pretty clear because what do we have
here we have just one by one matrix and
zero that's one with big complex numbers
from this disk and of course the angle
doesn't exceed PI over 2 it actually
doesn't exceed PI over 3 right so the
induction step how do we go from n minus
1 to N so PQ matrices like this and
assume that they differ
right so what do we can do we can expand
the permanent using the first row so the
permanent of a is the just Laplace
expansion the sum of a 1j the permanent
all the of the minor right so the sub
matrix that you get by crossing out the
first row in J's column and the same is
true for the permanent of B you get B 1
J but the minors will be the same right
because it's only the first row that
differ now what we do we look at any two
minors and we notice exactly what that
they differ at most 1 aj 1 aj 2
different in at most one column
so therefore by the induction hypothesis
the permanence not zero and the angle
don't exceed PI over two so the rest is
as promised middle-school exercise so
lemma which has nothing to do with
permanence or anything at all but plane
geometry so that if you have a nonzero
complex numbers where the angle between
any two not exceeding PI over two and if
you have a collection of numbers complex
numbers say alpha J better J within
distance point five from one then for
the linear combinations numbers and the
angle does not exceed PI over 2 and
that's a proof so I kind of like it so
it doesn't use anything by previous so
it's not the first proof I came up with
so my previous proofs used mathematics
and they've given me weaker constants
say the more mathematics I used the
weaker constants I was getting
so that's where I stopped at 0.5 I can't
improve it so 0.5 is optimal for this
particular proof but is certainly not
clear at all if it's off the wall
so and you have as an exercise homework
exercise to prove a similar result for
complex matrices where you get get give
more leeway for the real part but pinch
the imaginary part it pretty much goes
right yeah I like it
father to them so okay so I'm going to
move slowly in the direction sort of for
more murky waters like as we will have
this part on the open problems so the
next thing I'd like to talk about is the
chromatic polynomial and for which we
did the exercise so let's recall
right so I chromatic pulling on them so
given a graph no loops know my pledges
so we have a para Q coloring if the end
points of every edge call differently
right if for every edge
in the graph and so we introduced that
number of proper proper colorings chi of
Q the number of proper q colorings and
over the in class homework session we
proved that's indeed polynomial so we
proved that interesting representation
proved that it can be written as the sum
over all collections of edges including
the empty collection that's that's
perfectly alright so Q 2 the number of
connected components of the graph
induced on the same set of verses was
those edges and negative 1 to the named
number they're just in the collection
right so they're prime the number of
connected components
off the graph well the same set of
vertices so isolated versus still count
as connected components and the subset
so we did it right so that of course
allows us to define it for any complex
number
just by the very same formula by
renaming Q so and this provides a
marvelous example of interpolating from
infinity so interpolation from infinity
it was observed by his Rex who's here
and then observed again on the deeper
level why what did they observe they
observe that a conjecture by SoCo which
says that this polynomial is not zero
provided the real part is greater than
the largest degree
on the graph implies for example that
the number of like Delta plus 1 colors
coloring proper coloring can be
approximated in polynomial time wasn't
any error epsilon provided Delta fixing
is an in in advance so people tell me
that experimentally local conjecture
looks very plausible right yes so we
still don't know how to prove it so what
we do know though is there is a Sacco
theorem
which says that this polynomial has no
zeros if the absolute value of the
argument is greater than some constant
like social proof seven point nine times
the largest degree improved later six
point nine and I think was it improved
afterwards right so so basically what
what does it say so so what we know for
sure is that there are no zeros in the
sufficiently large disk large but
proportional only to the no I'm sorry
the right zero so here no zeros outside
no zeros outside outside
and we also conjecture conjectures that
there are no zeros in that half plane
right so then as his notice that can be
used to terpil eight very quickly namely
we interpolate not from zero like we did
last time but coming from infinity that
makes perfect intuitive sense because
it's much easier to call it grass
properly if you can use instantly many
colors very just color random right and
then you can kind of crawl knowing that
there are no zeros in the vicinity so
what do you do what they did so you
introduce the exhibiter polynomial so
you revert the coefficients so it'll be
neither V is the set of vertices times
the chromatic polynomial at the point 1
over Z and if we if we use these
expansions what do we get so we get so
it's the sum over all collections of
edges right including the empty
collection but this time we get Z to the
cardinality of the number the number
versus minus the number of connected
components right times the same negative
want
we have that so then what does SoCo
conjecture translating to so so Col
conjecture translates into the fact that
so if we use the what the inversion
right then this half plane translates
into the circle disk rather and this is
somewhere one over Delta so no zeros
here no zeros for that polynomial Sarco
theorem
translates into the fact that maybe I
should have used the different color how
about yeah I write so coke injection
green and the picture in green so Sokol
conjecture
so it says the three nila zeroes in the
disk so so-called theorem says that
there are no zeros in the small disk
around the origin so so-called theorem
no zeroes here right and we are up to
interpolation right so we got a strip a
zero free strip from 0 to 1 over Delta
plus 1 right so we can interpolate to 1
over Delta plus 1 provided we can
compute the first algorithmically many
derivatives right so can interpolate
this polynomial P provided
the derivatives are sort of accessible
so that the first few derivatives can be
computed easily but when we look at the
derivatives right sir so the case
derivative is what up to the of course
say K factorial right so what it is say
we just collect the sum over all
collection of edges which are very few
so that the number of connected
components that thing yet we get is
equal to K the K small then that
basically implies that
there are many connected components just
all every vertex is the connected
component except maybe some small number
of K which means that there are very few
edges we are talking about right so so
and that as prereqs noticed so for for
logarithmic aid can be computed in
polynomial time so can be computed in
some 2 to the of a time right and
therefore we are set to do interpolation
so we we know logarithmically many
derivatives we find them very quickly
and we have is there a free strip and we
just go there and that's as I understand
the the resultant count in Delta plus 1
right is still open right and so the
best is 11 over 6 times Delta right
11:06 minus epsilon times Delta by
Markov chain right so he used that well
he use this cluster expansion which
shows the power series for log log
partition function converges
exponentially fast and as as supported
on connected objects right well yes but
you can all
okay okay but but yeah right but this is
still to to do this hold
that's so quite enough right yet so we
need the SoCo
conjecture big okay right so that's an
example of things where things stand
they kind of open right we really don't
have much but probably serious parallel
graph something like this the problem if
you as I see it so the problem is that
when we want to prove something like
this then you can prove it by induction
anything else and for the induction we
ought to have a whole family of objects
somehow related by various in various
ways and here is only this ironic
polynomial and nothing around it but I'm
going to talk about some sort of trying
to make this problem sort of more
amenable kind of inductive argument but
before that so again any
objections
right so okay so what we'll do we'll try
to consider a more RAM sort of a broad
notion hoping to get something out of it
simple because she loves us more
flexiblity and that will be the
graphical murphy's and partition
functions
okay
how morphism partition function right so
what is this so we still have a graph
what's the same user on law assumptions
that no loops no mouths pledges we have
a symmetric matrix
besides Q by Q so that to allude to the
colouring question see symmetric
possibly complex right and what we do we
introduce a falling on now associate a
polynomial is the graph so it's the sum
over all maps or the set of vertices to
the set and then what we do they take
the product over all edges
whatever matrix entries we got so with
every graph and every Q therefore we
associated polynomial and the
interesting things that it encodes an
awful lot of things so for example how
does it relate to the chromatic
polynomial so if if your matrix is it's
just zeros in the diagonal right and
once off the diagonal then the value the
value is just the number of property
columns right so another hand if even
the for like 2 by 2 matrix so if a has
the structure is 0 in the corner once
outside than the value
is the number of independent sets so why
is that because the an independent set
will be the inverse image of one right
because we we don't want to the moment
we get to endpoints map-21
we pick up zero and the term disappears
right so therefore we just counting so
with every such a map we associate the
inverse image of one and that gives us
an intention and vice versa did I think
about this object is that we got more
flexibility we have like many variables
so that's something to use right so okay
so that's the object in again objections
by the way when did I start what do I
think so I just thought I finish a town
okay good so so with Pablo sovereign we
proved them zero freeness result for
this thing and actually to do induction
say the proof was very much similar to
the one I showed you for the permanent
right so it's the same idea so you embed
it in a bunch of related objects so what
we did we actually considered a more
general object because it looks like
that the more general object you have
the easier to induct right it it's not a
new observation say even more general so
assign a separate matrix use V to each
edge so what we get then we get this
object I'll still do note this
collection of matrices now by a so it's
the sum again overall numbering sort of
or colorings if you wish what spins are
versus and the product now picks up
the entry of the corresponding matrix
and the advantage of that is that we get
a really multi affine thing which is
easier to deal with so what we've proved
so we proved Arif rhiness so was
published on so if the entries are
within a certain distance that inversely
proportional to the largest degree
of the graph then then this functional
is not zero again so it's nonzero and
apologies so later I sort of simplified
the proof and kind of made the bound
better so so what what it looks now it
says the flat Delta sup Delta it's a
nice notation right say especially when
you kind of articulated the maximum of
the function
just write sine cosine so then this home
murph ism partition function is not 0
provided again the entries are within
that distance
the one right so in Pedigo we get pro
reasonably well you so so the first
interesting case when the degree three
right so we get like point in eighteen
roughly so DeForest point thirteen and
so forth and generally we have that
bound and so the proof as I said so it's
basically the same proof as a for the
permanent only with bells and whistles
instead of a permanent or sub-matrix you
have a graph how Murphy's and partition
function with additional constraints
that it maps some chosen vertices to
some chosen indices what is the same
sort of induction and looking at the
properties of the like vectors in the
accordion playing later I so that that's
a let's call it a disk disks theorem
so later I proved a strip theorem that
if you just care about real matrices
then you can get a better better bouncer
so what it looks like this is one disc
will prove the existence and so the
picture is the same as Aleister had so
this trip is longer so strip theorem
basically allows you to choose to choose
this Delta 3 if you pinch the the
imaginary part so Delta 3 will be
tangent of PI over 9 which proximately
point 36 so you can go from 1 both ways
by point 36 if the degree of every it's
the largest degree of the vertex is 3
and general formula for larger
is tangent Y over four times Delta minus
one or Delta greater than three soon
right but as you approach these numbers
so this trip becomes thinner and thinner
so the no zeros here so and then you
apply interpolation and you say that if
Delta is so a plus of course ideas to
compute into if you just imply it's a
vanilla
interpolation you get quasi polynomial
algorithm so interpolation gives you
quite a polynomial algorithm summation
Algar
and if we adhere the sorcery of Patel
and rags then in the in those domains
sliceable domains so we get polynomial
time out here if the largest degree six
okay so that's that's sufficiently
general object so what I do suggest that
we stare at it for fifteen seconds
for any issues
yeah so the observation for Elric so
when you when you do it like I did for
the permanent right so you'll be summing
up some polynomials over collection of
edges of logarithmic size and in
principle so if you just do it naively
as I do so that gives you
quasi-polynomial right into the log n
but what they noticed and for me it's
kind of nothing short of kind of sorcery
that somehow you can only restrict
yourself on to collection of edges that
are connected and then it becomes
polynomial on the fixed degree right
well they yes so that's what Allister
talked about yesterday so they
decomposed so not quite as product so
it's more like relations between Newton
psalms and between the moments and
elementary symmetric functions or
between if you wish between King lands
and moments
right so so one there are two remarks
I'd like to make
maybe I finally reach this slogan here
talking about stuff so what is a one
remark is how what is it a good for
first
what is it good for I'll use red for
that so so during this week I've been
bothering people asking like for your
application so previewing your question
here what is good for makes a living
yeah it's a very general question so far
by the way so I'm not so sure about the
nearest future the way things go
alright that's not getting bad so
suppose we want to solve some np-hard
problem so suppose we want to decide is
there a queue a proper coloring of the
graph
proper colouring
some mastic you right so I don't know
for cuticle three for some Q and Delta
which makes it hard so what we can do we
can attempt to let's compute the graph
from Murph ISM our partition function on
the matrix which instead of once on the
diagonal has one plus Delta
so whatever Delta I can afford money
soon and on the diagonal one - go
right so what I'm doing now so I'm
considering all colorings proper or not
but they're weighted exponentially so
proper coloring comes with weight 1 plus
Delta to the number of edges I guess
right and improper
wait it down
exponentially
by then up in the number of miscarriages
right so what does it bomb it it buzz me
something like that so if I look at this
number that I'm getting and if it's
small right then you probably say that
it's it's kind of far from being
properly colorable so the whatever color
colorings I take it will have
sufficiently many miss colored edges
right if it's large well then maybe just
maybe right there are sufficiently many
proper colorings even if the proper
coloring can be sort of exponentially
rare if you just try the colors random
so so they do some sort of a version of
the property testing right so they can
they allow you to separate drafts that
are far from being properly colorable
meaning that whatever coloring you take
they'll be sufficiently many improperly
colored edges from the graphs that have
a sufficiently many proper colorings as
if you have two graphs you look you
compare then this thing will tell you
the difference and still better than
nothing I think right said it's still
better than to say that the problem is
Sharpie hard and I refused to deal with
it
this is the model right so it covers
right post-mortal oh yes yes yes yes yes
right right right
this photo right so what I also like to
mention is that notice that the bounds
do not depend on the size of the matrix
which means that you can take a limit
and consider spin systems with
continuous spins right and that's what
you get you get into even for me even
murkier area of quantum using models in
the life but we'll probably can shed a
light on that so what's this model
what's the name of that model where you
allow like spins on a circle and sphere
okay right so so it it covers that right
because the bounds are independent on
the size of the matrix so you can take
limits
other other concerns or or objections so
very recently
yeah very recently the world a recent
paper boy his Davis Patel and bench
right so it's a very recent result so
when they wanted to go all the way so
here I stay round one we wanted to go to
zero but at the cost of making few large
enough and also with with the view
towards the SoCo conjecture
so that's it's in the archive so what
they consider it they consider a very
special matrix so a is of the type the
one off the diagonal so we're still
coloring our complex number Z on the
diagonal but he is large so they proved
the existence of the strip all the way
from zero to one so the zero freenas
and as a culinary blind interpolation
argument so the Poland polynomial time
approximation algorithm provided so
there are friends in the strip so that's
where Z varies I provided our Q is
sufficiently large it's approximately
3.2 Delta and here's telling me that
it's actually heat
right so actually actually e times Delta
and there is still hope that you can put
any number greater than one and that
would do a proper coloring so the proof
is is a bit more convoluted version of
the proof for the permanent but you
would probably agree the
its some inspire the permanent of this
little scone computation so but it's
much more involved so and as I
understand so it may well be that this e
can be replaced by 1 plus epsilon we
don't know it's look if it's true it
looks easier than soccer conjecture yes
so maybe maybe just maybe greater than 1
and if we do then the interpolation does
coloring
okay so I think my time is up right is
that right yeah okay jolly good say
again any any any reaction any time so
circle theorem using this induction I
well I can't take Peter C query proof
okay's people which kind of goes by
induction but not this type right what
is this inductive argument right from
that's how I learned it anyhow so
computers paper which makes a difference
on asleep when you read it these little
simplifications here and there but it's
essentially inductive argument right if
you look at the cadets key price right
so it's still inductive argument right
so so it's probably fair to say that all
these things are proven by induction
isn't the same as this bound many many
people share so-called Scott diversion
bound it's essentially the same boundary
and that bondage is inductive bound
right like like we did
in circles here a thing is that so the
real line is inductive but then go from
the real line to the complex
I'm sorry neurosis right
oh that I don't think he I'm sorry I
don't thinking well they're expert here
but I think I was out right without sign
an alternation probably just by strictly
by induction I think I did it actually
in my book
well of course I I didn't do it I just
lifted it off no on the complex contact
complex complex right the real reals are
not interesting so off to pattern ends
[Applause]